[Applause]
thank you very much for this
introduction it's a great pleasure and
honor to give this open lecture to such
a diverse audience today so I hope I can
cater for the majority of people in this
room so my title is in pursuit of
structure why little randomness almost
always helps the first type of structure
I'd like to explain to you is the
structure of my talk so first I'll tell
you about some very old problems in
number theory I'm not quite so old
problem that looks a little less number
theoretic I'll try to explain why random
is good I think many of you are familiar
with some general theme and why random
looking is still pretty good and why
neither is likely to be the end of this
story okay now what kind of mathematical
structure am I going to talk about so
I'll first talk about the problem of
adding two primes there's a very famous
conjecture due to GABA which goes back
to a letter the Goldbach wrote to Euler
in 1740 to which you see here on the
left so he conjectured that every even
integer greater than 2 can be written as
the sum of two primes for example you
can write 20 as a sum of 13 plus 7 or 34
as a summer 31 plus 3 I am extremely
worried and in one of my examples
there's going to be a number that's not
a prime over there I did check them
twice today but it may still happen
[Music]
and we do know this we can check this
conjecture computationally and it's
known up to some very very large number
just by people kind of doing computation
and but the conjecture itself as stated
is still wide open and believed to be
very difficult
we know that the conjecture is true for
almost all even numbers and various
other weak variants which I'll explain
to you in a moment now why is this a
structural result about numbers because
it's essentially saying that the even
numbers can be represented as the subset
of the set of prime that's not quite
true of course I see Chantal I'm a short
look on her face because two of the
prime and so you can get some odd
numbers in the left hand in the right
hand except that it is approximately
true or should be true okay what we can
prove is a weaker version of the
statement may be that every odd integer
greater than five can be written as a
sum of three Prime's now that happens to
be easier because you have one more
degree of freedom so in this as stated
this was actually proved by Herald
health rot in 2013 so he was a member in
the program at mfri and a speaker in our
first workshop on expanders in our
program in january and there's a lot of
work that came before so he improved on
a sort of long-standing method but
really closed this conjecture for good
now I wanted to tell you about a second
problem so here you see some numbers
eleven thirteen so I didn't make these
up so some of these are not primes
it's not my heart 269 and 271 so these
are so-called twin prime pairs so both
of these numbers are prime and their
assistance to
and many of you will be familiar with
the following famous conjecture which is
a twin prime conjecture and which says
there are infinitely many Prime's P such
that P plus 2 is also prime again I have
some examples for you so 1113 51:43 and
possibly a few others that you can see
on the left and mathematically would you
like to prove is that the limits of P n
plus 1 which is the M soft first prime
minus P n is at most which is the M
prime is at most 2 and the reason I've
stated it like this is because I on the
next slide want to show you some recent
progress on this so this is work on
bounded gaps and primes
so there's another major breakthrough in
2013 new tank zhang showed that in fact
this limit is bounded so he couldn't
show that they were standard by two but
it is bounded this was a huge
breakthrough because previously we only
had a bound that was growing as a
function of n on this quantity here now
in a shortly afterwards james main
island parents how and independently
found a different approach and
approaches different from Jiang's and in
fact that gives a bound of about 246 on
this quantity so it's a very explicit
number there was some involvement of a
polymath project as well in getting that
number down to something very reasonable
but so 246 is not 2 but it's much closer
to 2 than a function tending to infinity
this is a picture of James May not he is
the co-organizers of our joint mfri food
around the mus seminar and i don't see
him right now
excellent I want to tell you about a
third problem which is to do with the
Third Kind of structures you
might want to look for in the primes and
that's an arithmetic progression so as
we've mentioned by dick in the
introduction a very famous result in our
area of research is our so-called green
power theorem so this would be the spend
green and Terrance house this is
actually a picture taken in Berkeley in
2008 when they we were all attending a
program at MSR I this was on the roof of
the building that I lived in other times
and it was shortly after they prove
they're celebrated theorem and that just
states that there are arbitrarily long
arithmetic progression in the prime so
they prove this around 2004 but the
conjecture goes back to at least 1770 so
I told you I was going to talk about
some pretty old problems I think this
council well in fact they proved
something stronger than this not just do
the primes themselves contain
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
but any sufficiently dense subset of the
primes contain such progressions there's
a lot of work that followed this
breakthrough result different kinds of
arithmetic structures that we can find
in the primes now we can also count
these types of configurations very
exactly so we can give us an topics for
all of these structures there's a lot of
work that came out of this development
so again I wanted to show you an example
so 713 and 90 that's a three term
arithmetic progression in primes and
here's a slightly larger one so that is
a progression of length 24 which is a
number I don't even know what that
number is but it's very large it was
found in 2007 by Wroblewski and some
longer ones unknown but when you do want
to find arbitrarily long progressions so
if you want to find an arithmetic
progression of length say 50 or 60 you
need to go pretty filed to make that
happen okay
what do all of these problems have in
common
so Lisa superficially they are all about
primes and about additive relations
between primes and the reason these
problems are so hard and where many of
these conjectures remain open for such a
long time is that the primes are not
fundamentally multiplicative objects
they're they're multiplicative atoms of
our universe event integers right every
integer is made up of prime factors by
multiplication whereas the structures
that we study here at additive
structures so we look at twin primes
that's at Prime and a prime plus two
writing and even integers of sum of two
primes and in the case of arithmetic
progressions looking for configurations
of the form X x + DX 2 DX + 3 D all of
these are additive configurations now a
lot of progress has relied on
understanding exactly how random pseudo
random the prime is really off so I've
printed the first while they're Prime's
up to I don't know 86 for you here or
rather the indicator function of the
primes up to 86 so takes the value 1
when the number is a prime and 0
otherwise and you can see I look fairly
well distributed
looks like they get a bit sparse as you
go along but you don't see any obvious
kind of structure here so the way we
think about primes is often using
probabilistic models and there's one
particular model that's been very
successful in making all kinds of
predictions about the types of
configurations we looked at on the first
few slides and that's the cry Mair model
basically says the following in a very
naive form so the asymptotic statistics
for the set of prime
P should roughly equal the asymptotic
statistics of the random set P prime
where an integer n is chosen to lie in P
prime with probability 1 over log n now
the 1 over log n comes from the prime
number theorem so we know that it gave
it interval 1 up to n there are n over
log n Prime's
so this is the frequency with which you
expect a prime and you can naively try
and model the set of primes by just
choosing an integer to be a prime with
probability 1 over log n now this
doesn't it gives you quite a lot of
things it doesn't quite work so for
example you could try and predict the
number of asymptotics of the number of
twin primes and that we expect to have
asymptotically using this heuristic it
gives you the right prediction but it
also gives you the prediction for the
number of pairs P P plus 1 that are both
prime and that's obviously nonsense
because there are no Prime's that are
just prime pairs that are 1 apart the
primes other than 2 even and so you have
to adjust this slightly and the way you
do that is by taking into account the
bias that they're trying to have with
respect to small modular modular classes
so for example I just said that all the
primes above 2 even so that means that
you're not going to find any crimes in
the residue class 0 mod 2 it's also true
that no prime is a multiple of 3 so
you're not going to find any Prime's and
the residue class 0 mod 3 and you can
exclude a lot of the natural bias that
the primes have by adjusting your model
you ran the model in this way by
basically taking care of this vyas of
the primes with respect to the storm
revenue classes and that gives you our
best predictions current predictions the
do and coincide with the results we've
obtained so far on the problems that I
sketched on the first few slides there
are other around the models of the
primes for example you can use random
matrices to model statistics of the
primes these are more appropriate when
you want to describe multiplicative
behavior of crimes and they're certainly
not the subject of today's talks this
kind of random model this notion of
pseudo randomness largely applies for
the first two problems I talked about so
these the things you're interested in
studying when you're interested in
Goldbach conjecture and in the twin
prime conjecture so they're less
relevant for studying the third type of
problem that I described
memory arithmetic progressions and in
primes in fact we believe the green
towel theorem is true independently of
the fact that we're looking for
structure in the set of primes right the
green tiles theorem shouldn't really be
a result about primes at all I'll
explain to you the sense in which we
believe that that's true in fact we
believe and we know that any
sufficiently dense subset of the
integers contains arbitrarily long
arithmetic progression that's some
radius theorem from 1975 unfortunately
it's not quite good enough to give you
the primes result I'll show about to you
in a second first I'll show you a
picture of Andreas I'm ready after the
place where he I think this is the árbol
Prize ceremony okay
now more precisely we know that
if aids are substituted the first
integers and larger than n over let's
say log log n to some small power for
some small power C then a contains an
arithmetic progression of length K yes
think of K equals 2,100 whatever you
like some fixed number okay and this
small competency depends on on okay now
that's the result and it's due to Tim
Gower's
and in fact you may notice that I've
clipped both of these photos out of a
larger one the person in the middle may
be familiar to many of you - that's how
many mechanisms so I could fill an
entire electrical oh that went wrong I'm
talking about this result and the
methods that go into it what I'm not
going to do that I will only point out
to you but the primes have density 1
over log N and in particular that's
smaller than this number here at the
moment right so if you wanted to just
apply some Rayleigh theorem to the
primes unfortunately at our current
level of understanding you cannot apply
to the primes because of primes or to
spark however we do believe that this is
not the optimal bound in fact we have a
lower bound so a construction of a large
set that does not contain any K term
arithmetic progressions that's roughly
of density e to the minus C log n sort
of one log case root of log n which is
yes which is a long way away from
showing this number here in fact even in
the very simplest case where K equals 3
if we just look looking to find the
three-term arithmetic progression there
is still a gap between the upper and a
lower bound for this problem so the
current best-known upper bound is Jude -
Tom bloom who is a Simon fellow at the
moment he's not yet and based on work of
Tom Saunders who's also currently a
visitor and the program and this lower
bound is an old one sir but for K for
three there's some progressive alkyne
and Ben green and myself okay now I said
we forget about the primes altogether
and in fact I want to simplify the
problem I said we'd forget about the
primes altogether and we concentrate on
the case K equals 3 so we're just
looking for three time arithmetic
progression and I'm going to now
simplify the problem even further forget
about the integers we're going to move
the toys setting which especially
computer scientists will be very
familiar with so we're looking at a
vector space over a finite field and
I'll explain to you what the cat said
problem is okay the question is how
large does a subset a of F 3 to the N
have to be before it is guaranteed to
contain a three term arithmetic
progression right so if you replace F 3
to the n with the integers then you have
the sort of Table three case of Rock
theorem why is this called the cap set
problem while a cat set for some
historic reason is a set that contains
no three APs
so the cap sub-problem asks what is the
maximal size of a cap set now why are we
looking at F 3 to the N I know computer
scientists prefer f2 to the M I can't
really make sense of a three term
progression in f2 to the N because
there's any zero and one
there are versions of this problem that
you can formulate enough to to the em
with the real analog is in 3 to the N
and the reason I want to talk about a
three-term progression rather than a
configuration of the form X plus y
equals Z which you could have an f2 to
the end is that I want the configuration
to be translation invariant now actually
if you think about it in F 3 to the N a
three term progression is actually just
three points on a line so it's really a
very simple object okay now how large
can I cap said B I can certainly very
easily construct for you a cap set of
size 2 to the end I simply take all the
vectors in F 3 to the N whose
coordinates are only 0 and 1 there are 2
to the N of them and that set certainly
bill can contain 3 points on a line
because once I've taken a step in one
direction I have to take another steps
and then I'm out of my set so there's a
trivial lower bound of 2 to the N on the
maximal size of a cap set in fact it's
been known for over a decade and this is
a result of Idul and the bare offsets
cap sets that are of size 2.2 174 to the
answer slightly better two relatively
complicated construction and the number
is a number that you can generate and
we've also known for about that long
that a cap side can have size at most a
constant times 3 to the n divided by n
let me decode this for you 3 to the N is
the total size of my space so the
density of this set is a constant
divided by n so tends to 0 as n goes to
infinity so these caps have certainly
has vanishingly small density
and I will tell you a little bit about
how you prove this particular result
which is due to mesh ulam from 1996 the
reason I want to tell you about this is
not so much because I believe that this
problem is is hugely important what is
important is the tools that go into
addressing this problem that have been
developed to improve the bounds on this
problem because they've been used in
many other instances across mathematics
and computer science ok so what are
these tools so this is a second way in
which we use the notion of pseudo
randomness in this branch of mathematics
so the first way remember was to say
that ie I use the idea of pseudo
randomness to model the behavior of the
primes right so I'm going to do
something quite different here so let's
think about what would we expect over
truly random set in F 3 to the N so if
my subset a of F 3 to the N was truly
around them said let's say we choose the
elements of a independently at random
with probability alpha so the expected
size of our set is alpha times 3 to the
n how many three term arithmetic
progressions would it contain with high
probability well how many 3 time
progressions are there in total so I can
choose the first point that's 3 to the N
choices and the second point which is 3
to the N again if I have 3 to the N
squared many 3 term progressions how
many of these lie in the set a if I've
chosen it in the penalty and run random
with probability alpha I'll have alpha
cubed 3 to the N squared many 3 ApS
we're also the density of myself and
what's really surprising about this or
perhaps is slightly counterintuitive is
that you know in the random said I know
nothing about its structure and yet I
think count the number of creativeness
has with almost complete accuracy
so we'd like to have a notion of pseudo
randomness that replicates this behavior
and it applies to a larger range of sets
than just a truly random one so what
will work for us is we'll say that a
subset a is super random if it's
indicator function has vanishingly small
Fourier transform at non trivial
frequencies I'll tell you what I mean by
their Fourier transform in this context
this is an awful formula first and last
time I'll use a PowerPoint presentation
for a max talk so the indicator function
once of a as a function that takes the
values 1 when X is in a and 0 otherwise
the Fourier transform and any point TN s
3 to the N is just the sum over all
elements X and F 3 to the N the
interpretive function times the third
root of unity X dot T where X dot T is
the scalar product in F 3 to the N so X
dot T here can take 3 different values
mob 3 0 1 or 2 and this sum you should
think of it as normalized for everything
that I'm going to say now
otherwise it won't make much sense so I
divided by the size of the so the group
which is 3 to the N ok now the first
thing we observe about this Fourier
transform is that AB 0 so the trivial
Faru coefficient which I can just plug
into the formula actually find I have
the normalized sum over the indicator
function of X and that's actually just
the size of a divided by the size of the
group so that gives me the density of
the set and it's also not difficult to
see just intuitively that this is the
largest value that the Fourier
coefficient can ever take right because
there is no cancellation at all from the
complex phase so all of your furro
coefficients of this indicator function
are going to be an absolute value at
most alpha the density of the set
okay I'll call this set pseudorandom if
in fact all of the non-trivial Fourier
coefficients are really a lot smaller so
I actually want them to go to 0 as the
dimension of my space little n goes to
infinity okay and I claim that if set a
is pseudo-random in this sense but its
indicator function has vanishingly small
Fourier transform at non-trivial
frequencies then it does actually have
the same number of 3 ApS as a random set
and that's really good news right so
this is the notion of pseudo randomness
that we want to use when we're
interested in counting 3 ApS because
they're now a pseudo-random sets
actually behave like random sets and the
reason for this the proof of this is
really really easy I'm not going to give
it to you but it essentially relies on
the fact that I can rewrite a number of
3 ApS in a as the sum of these three
coefficients of the sum over t1 survey
half of T cubed there's some complex
conjugates lines missing but this is
roughly what it is and this is a very
nice expression to work with and you can
see that the trivial for a coefficient
contributes an alpha cubed here which is
the domain term and I see remaining
coefficients are small them you know
they don't contribute anything much and
indeed a random set it's not hard to see
is actually pseudo-random and descent
setup subs good news but more
importantly there are other there's
there's a larger class of set that are
pseudo random in the sense they are not
truly random so for example there's some
quadratic varieties which satisfy this
illness is very important ok now what
you do with this you can iterate this or
use this as a basis for an iteration to
get the the upper bound that I stated
for you before namely that the cap set
so a set with no three APs and F 3 to
the N is bounded above by a constant
times 3 to the N divided by n ok
so this is how this goes so either my
settee is sued around them in which case
actually we just saw that it has a lot
of these three term progressions namely
alpha cube 3 to the N squared but hey
that can't be right because I'm actually
assuming that my set has no free AP's at
all so therefore it can't be sued around
them and what does that mean just by
definition it means it must have a large
free coefficient it must have at least
one large fro coefficient so let's look
at this for a coefficient again what was
it it was a sum of these ones or zeros
multiplied by this complex phase right
but this complex phase can only take
three values depending on the residue
classes X dot T right T is fixed got one
large for a coefficient so if this
coefficient is large for some nonzero T
that means that one of these three
residue classes zero one or two mod
three must get more than its fair share
of hits from a because otherwise you'd
get complete cancellation in this sum
what does it mean that one of the three
residue classes of X dot T gets more
than its fair share of contributions
from a that means that a actually is
biased towards one of the these
subspaces defined by X dot T equals zero
okay and that tells me that a has sort
of very large density or larger density
than on average on this subspace of co
dimension one which is a determined by
the orthogonal complement of T ok so
that's great so I have a set now that is
a bit denser on a portion of the space
it still has no three APs and I can just
run this argument again and I do this
until I must stop because I run out of
dimension or because the density of the
set has got so big that it's actually
bigger than one and you trade these two
things off against each other
quantitatively and this is what you get
so the reason I tell you about this in
quite a bit of detail is because really
all of the solutions to these summer 80s
high problems on arithmetic progressions
follow more or less this blueprint right
there is a notion of pseudo randomness
that tells you if your set is pseudo
random actually I can count the number
of progressions or the number of
configurations but I like to count
pretty exactly and then you have to
conclude something about you know when
my when your set is not pseudo-random
and you expect to get some structural
result and you can kind of code this up
more compactly in the sort of following
statement but really what we've done is
we've sort of written the characteristic
function of a as a sum G Plus H where my
G is structured in the sense that it is
constant and large subspaces of F 3 to
the N and the function H is a pseudo
random error and a pseudo randomness in
this case being defined as as the
function H having vanishingly small
Fourier coefficients and so what matters
for counting 3 ApS is just the function
G ok
and I can rewrite this yet again to say
really our aim given a set a our aim is
to find a function G which were
proximate 1 sub a up to a pseudo random
error and this is a very very general
statement that is is ubiquitous in our
and area of research and I'll give you a
couple of examples of how this can be
extended so the first application of
this type of approximation statement is
it actually can give you much stronger
information about the large Fourier
spectrum of a set so you know from parts
of our theorem that a set can't have too
many large Fourier coefficients but
actually you can have a much
stronger information about their
algebraic structure and that's very
helpful in many contexts these sort of
statements as I've already alluded to
can also be obtained for other notions
of pseudo randomness so in particular
when you start to look at progressions
that are of length greater than two
three you need to define other notions
of pseudo randomness in particular we
work with the so called gallows
uniformity norms so you want
approximations of this type where your
function H is a pseudo random in a more
sophisticated sense and that leads to
the whole subject of higher Furi
analysis high order free analysis which
I have worked on quite a bit and the
number of applications to computer
science including
pseudo-random generators etcetera and
finally you might want to obtain in a
number of contexts including the Green
calcium you you want to obtain these
kinds of statements approximation
statements not just for the indicator
function of this dense set one survey
but also for unbounded functions so
answer this and Mangold function for
example which is unbounded and which
kind of sub scissor the indicator
function for the prime so the fact that
this function is unbounded is a an
indication of the set of prime is being
very sparse as you have to renormalize
this so if you want to prove something
like the green cow serum you you will
have to approximate an unbounded
function in this way and in computer
science and that's a statement that's
called a dense model theorem and which
can also be used to prove an impulsive
hard core set lemma and various other
types of weak regularity type statements
and in particular I want to point out to
the people on the machine learning
program that techniques from machine
learning a particular boosting
algorithms have been used to obtain
these kinds of approximations
so for various notions of pseudo
randomness okay now most importantly
from a from a number theoretic point of
view you can obtain these kinds of
statements not just an f32 the end which
is a group that we're interested in
because it's kind of nice and simple and
it has these subspaces etc but you can
also prove these statements in the
integers and there is sort of there is a
there's a mechanism by which you
translate these results from this
setting of s3 to the N to the integers
it's it's very technical but it can be
done now I have a I do have 12 more
minutes before we get to the final part
of the talk I have a brief diversion
because I did mention a card game in the
abstract for the talk so I thought I
should briefly talk about that in case
somebody was expecting me to okay so
there is a card game which some of you
may have played I see some people
nodding here unfortunate I don't have it
with me because it's in my office in the
UK but it is actually a really good game
you do need to be awake though okay it's
a very simple game played with a deck of
81 cards you notice that 81 is a power
of three three to the four in particular
so each of these cards display the
number one two or three of shapes
actually I'll show you a picture there
we go
diamond squiggle or oval in one of three
colors green red or purple and filled
with some kind of shading so solid empty
or you can't see this very well but it's
two strokes okay so that makes a key one
different cards and a combinations of
three cars is very confusingly called a
set if for each of these four attributes
all three cards are either the same or
they're all different
so I'll give you some examples okay this
is a set because they're all purple
they're all solid they're all squiggles
and you have the numbers one two and
three give you another example this is a
set because they're all solid you've got
red green purple squiggle diamond oval
and there's something I'm missing
oh and two one three okay this is not a
set because the three occurs twice there
you want to find a set yes very good
okay so I think many of you in the will
have spotted that you can associate to
each color vector in three to the fall
and so in fact a set is just a line in F
3 to the 4 so it's three points on a
line and the way this game is actually
played is that the dealer could setting
12 cards on the table and then people
start shouting out set if they spot one
the point is you're not guaranteed a set
in any set of 12 cards that's on the
table so the question is how many how
many cards do you need to have on the
table before you somebody is guaranteed
a set and I think so in this particular
game so in four dimensions there's the
answer is 20 and the cap set problem is
just the n-dimensional version of this
of this question
okay now that I've spent the first half
an hour telling you how we use these
pseudo random methods and sort of this
analytic machinery to solve card games
all the real point of this talk is to
actually tell you about a totally
non-random breakthrough from last year
which is really called a lot of this
methodology and sixth question so crude
11 pas surprised the additive
combinatorial community in May 2016 with
a very short preprint that addressed the
the caps head problem not in s 3 to the
end but in Z mod 4 to the N which is
slightly different but eventually
they're there their method led to a
polynomial bound on the size of civic
root less and pastori to a polynomial
bound on the size of a cap set which is
a form two point two seven five six to
the N and this was done by
allenburg and high side but in heavily
relied on on the initial ideas of crude
xi power which initially looked like
they really were very specific to red
mod for bed but allenburg in height were
able to adapt them to 2 F 3 to the N now
the amazing thing about those preprint
is that it's very short and the method
is really quite Elementary so I will try
and give you a sketch in the last five
minutes of this talk of how this goes
remember that the previous bound that I
sketched to you obtained using analytic
method will of the form 3 to the N
divided by n so this is really a huge
breakthrough in particular it almost
looks like the lower bound which was of
the form to point to several full I
don't remember but the numbers are I
mean they're not identical but
this looks much more like we're in the
right ballpark okay
and I said that the the method of proof
is quite Elementary so it relies on an
idea that's actually quite old and there
has been used repeatedly in combinatory
over the past 30 40 years and that's the
following you want to find a low degree
polynomial key and which vanishes on on
the settee
that you're studying right so we all
know that a polynomial of degree D can
have at most D roots you can adapt that
to various fields that statement and so
it means that if you find something
that's relatively small a polynomial of
relatively small degree and it vanishes
on Aid and a can't be too large it's a
pretty simple approach now of course
it's not at all clear how you actually
find this polynomial and in particular
something about this polynomial has to
reflect the structure of your problem so
somehow you have to take advantage of
the fact that you're set a contains no
three term progressions right and in
practice actually this polynomial method
is quite far from the way that the
polynomial method has been applied and
has previously been applied in
combinatorics and it's articulated this
is a new mission of so-called slight
rank which I'll explain to you on the
next slide
ok so I have one tactical slide ok this
is a statement that's the entire proof
relies on so suppose I have a polynomial
P which is such the peak of a plus B is
0 for all distinct a and B n a and then
I claim that there aren't too many
elements of a to which P of minus a is
nonzero I can could tell you exactly in
fact you'll see in the proof what this
means it's not too large ok so we will
prove this at least in outline ok
so take any polynomial P or be any
polynomial and and variables of total
degree at most D and we will fix for
noun D is an arbitrary degree and we
will fix it much later in the proof and
we want to write P of x plus y as
follows so I'll write it as a sum while
a linear combination of monomials in x
and y these monomials are indicated by M
and M prime what's some coefficients and
the point is this M times M Prime has
degree at most C because we said he was
a polynomial of degree at most D but
that means looking at any single one of
these products at least one of M and M
Prime has to have degree at most B over
2 alright so I can actually break this
down further into a sum over monomials
and x times some polynomial in Y which
depends on the monomial plus some of the
monomials in Y times some polynomial in
X and where these sums are other
monomials of degree at most B over 2
right because I'm either here or that ok
now I want us to consider the matrix P
of a plus V for a little a and little B
in a so I claimed this is a matrix of
size a size of a times size of a so
that's pretty obvious I think we're good
here we're also assuming that P of a
plus B is 0 for all distinct a and B n a
so it's a diagonal matrix right very
nice matrix and what about the diagonal
entries the diagonal entries are of the
form P of little a Plock little a so 2a
and s3 that's
a so those are exactly the entries we're
interested in counting is that we want
to count how many nonzero diagonal
entries there are okay that actually
just means we want to get given upper
bound on the rank of this matrix okay
now you see why I've decomposed it in
this way because P of X of Y is a linear
cop Y is a sum to sum of of matrices
each of which has rank one so M of X
times F M of Y you see that all of the
rows are multiples of each other and the
same way over here so I have a sum of
matrices of Rank 1 and so the rank of
this matrix is at most the sum of these
ranks and how many elements are there in
each of these sums so that's a number of
monomials of degree at most D over 2 and
we have because we have two sums that we
have that the number of a a so which P
is minus a is not zero at most twice the
number of monomials of degree at most D
over 2 and what's that got to do with
the cap set you asked all the crucial
observation is that the set a plus a
which I so there's something missing in
the middle so that's the diagonal
element so I want the sum little a and
little B I want a and B to be distinct
in the sunset and minus a a disjoint
right because if they have an
intersection I'd have a 380 and then me
a solution to the equation a plus B
equals minus C or a plus B equals to C
so they're disjoint what we're going to
do not in any detail is choose a
polynomial P with maximal support form
all polynomials of degree D that are
supported on - a why do I want my
polynomial to be supported on - a
because then I know that it's going to
be 0 on this set here
right and then I can apply my lemma
simple counting tells you that a
supportive peers bounded below in terms
of DNA and the lemma gives you an upper
bound on the support of P and you play
these two off against each other and you
choose D in an appropriate way and
that's it now what's really important
about this and you hopefully see this
from the proof that this is a completely
different approach to the iteration
argument that I sketched to you in the
first half of the talk and I'll conclude
with some remarks and open problems for
the first one is very obvious now is
this upper bound actually tight which is
correct the upper or the lower bound we
have at the moment it turns out that
this polynomial method also solves a
various related problems and for some of
these problems the bound resulting from
this method has been shown to be tight
so in particular this is the
multicolored some free set problem so
but we don't know what the answer is to
this question at the moment does this
approach generalize food of counting or
finding bound all sets ok don't contain
any longer arithmetic progressions those
with the analytic approach there's a
huge increase in difficulty going from
310 progressions to 4 to 5 it doesn't
obviously work so people have tried this
can you apply this in the original
setting the integers the primes we don't
know how to do that what other
applications does it have so they have
been as as I already mentioned this has
been applied to a few variants of this
type of question and indeed some that's
looked less obvious but it's also been
shown to rule out
approaches to improving the explained as
a matrix multiplication there has been
devised by Conan o month so in their
group theoretic framework but the
philosophical question I want to leave
you with really have we've been kind of
barking up the completely wrong tree for
about half a century trying to refine
our analytic methods to get better
results if a simple polynomial proof can
give it to you in a page and a half so
thank you very much I'll take questions
over cookie if there are any left yeah
[Applause]